one thing that's for sure
Caitlyn does not want to be traditional
hashtag not your basic bride
I feel like now we should really try on
some dresses okay having a bride
physically try on the dresses is
everything to the creative process I get
insight on what silhouettes work best
what proportions to master and what
elements excite her oh my gosh do you
feel as magic Ozzy look I feel magical I
really do first I put Caitlyn in the
kenny dress mainly because it's my
perfect aline silhouette there was a
nice little slick for the can-can and I
loved the plunging neckline yeah I love
it too
this is look number one we're gonna put
this on our vision board okay perfect I
do really like this one though I don't
really want to get out of it you can
stand it all that okay it's totally
acceptable oh my gosh she or she greater
chic next up the Nash because hello
sheer why not we need to see how daring
she's willing to go I didn't think I
would like the feathers and I put it on
and I was like I like the feathers it
also is an embroidery which gives you
the appearance of it being lace if
there's just like a little bit of more
of a textural quality to it the color
factor is great you have some blush
tones the idea of two dresses maybe this
could be like the fun party dress oh
good I love that for my wedding I kind
of took a more is more approach and more
five different dresses naturally I'm
totally psyched that Caitlyn has decided
to at least go with two what if I keep
just liking dresses and then I end up
with five at the end that's what I did
the feels the feel yeah I get the feels
with this one the final look is the
league out I love the fact that this is
a classic lace but jazzed up with some
bios strapping and sexier elements I
really like the layering of it there's
something so angelic and effortless
about the chiffon skirt you still get
kind of like the flowy a-line shape but
it's a lot more movement - and hello a
little peekaboo factor there I need a
little bit of them then what do we think
about the lace I think I've pictured
myself in a little bit of lace and then
this gives it still edge everything
seems to be working very nicely and I
surprised myself with what I liked
that's exactly what this process is
about it's super exciting to be able to
dress Kaitlyn on her wedding day
[Music]